what is up reject nation we're gonna
watch
one division episode one on disney plus
it's been such a busy day
suddenly when like tim's sitting down i
am so excited
we're gonna watch one division it's so
cool guys if you're brand new subscribe
hit that notification bell to get
notified when our next one division
reaction is up if you enjoyed this video
please go ahead
hit that like button and as per usual
full-length reaction watch alongs where
you sync up with the time code or all
over at our patreon page this qualifies
as reaction
highlights thank you to everyone who's
joined our patreon page so far we're
over there we got so many shows at the
same tier you got the option for
reaction highlights and
watch alongs really excited to get into
this i finally read like the eight
issues of house of m
extra marvel juice to pump myself up
it's a cool story for something that is
only
loosely inspired it's not gonna feature
most of this
also gotta thank our buddy eric over at
nerd cronic for editing these reaction
highlights for us our savior on so many
shows of
last year please give him a follow the
edits for folks like movie trivia
schmodown a whole bunch of other
reactors as well
and on top of that he's just a great
friend anywho
guys let's do this
that's crazy you're getting like the
official wow
here we go
let's see what we got
what do you say to silver dollar
pancakes i say
oh i don't eat food
i'm i'm hungry well that's me off to
work then
oh don't forget
to see paul bettany's beautiful face
he's actually going to leave partway
through the season because he just
doesn't want to be in the makeup anymore
my mother-in-law was in town so i wasn't
so what's a single girl like you doing
rattling around this big house oh no i'm
not single
oh i don't see a ring he'll be home
later tonight for a special occasion
just the two of us
an anniversary then yet
[Laughter]
oh wow they have cashed this perfectly
yeah
oh this is gonna be a gas
guess this is gonna be a gas
that's cheating man that's cheating
would you be so good as to tell me
what it is we do here exactly
and no one can process the data quite
like you do pal you're like a
walking computer i'm most certainly i'm
not ooh
yes wife and i are looking forward to
this evening
mr hart of course ah
his name did stand out employee dinners
are a rite of passage for the new hires
ah isn't that right oh the wife thought
five courses would be sufficient
there was that paltry excuse for
entertainment a string quartet
display of speednik enthusiasm i wore a
turtleneck
oh all right and you got that mustache
commie no skeletons in your closet a
vision
i don't have a skeleton sir
the only thing suspicious is your name's
vision
what's the origin of that what about
seduction techniques
do i have those of course you do
you could point out that the death rate
of single men is twice that of married
men
now that's romantic
you hear that john guys that's the the
trick i need to start using
ladies
i might die
nervous whatever for well you're not
darling i still get a little tongue tied
no no i think the best cause of action
is to impress the wife and i think the
best course of action is to
impress the husband
oh how cool they even have a cut to
commercialization tired of you burning
his toast
what try our new and improved toastmate
2000.
it's the go-to for clever housewives
from meatloaf
to cherry pie to open-faced cheese
sandwiches you get a cherry pie slice in
that thing
color oh damn good call toastmate2000
by stark industries
oh how very literally the mom from that
70s
yeah pardon me while i just go and fetch
the lady of the house
worry [ __ ] oh
oh no oh it's awkward
traditional sokovian greetings
and that dress yes it's it's it's so
so cobian is
[Laughter]
[Music]
on the calendar was an abbreviation you
move at the speed of sound and i can
make a pen float through the air
who needs to abbreviate
[Laughter]
fair point your boss and his wife are
expecting a home-cooked meal
exactly magically make it happen i might
have a better idea
well thank you agnes i think i've got it
covered from here are you sure do you
many hands make light work and many
mouths make good gossip
all right then well i know you're in a
pinch so this menu can be done
no that's great please don't you can't
take out the papers and the trash why
don't we have a nice
sing-along all together then shall we
dude betty's having a ball
the most fun i've seen him have in a
long time
oh come on wanda focus up he calls you
diane yes it's
full of me i'm just coming
fred
dude he's so good he's so good
and i think they said they really did a
live audience thing too so like
oh god were either of you aware that
married men are killing single men at an
alarming rate
[Laughter]
well i think tonight's going swimmingly
you know i had high hopes for you but
from what i've seen here tonight
you can barely keep it together dinner
is served
breakfast for dinner don't knock it oh
very uh
european so covey
what brought you here how long have you
been married and why don't you have
children yet
sorry
yes we moved from avengers headquarters
the mind stone why did you come here
why damn it why
why did you damn it you said damn it
yeah stop it
stop it stop it
stop it stop it
stop it stop it
oh let me help you up i guess you're
keeping your job at least
well would you look at the time
[Laughter]
we'll see about that promotion huh yes
sir thank you
oh i don't care where this show goes
we need to find out if he gets that's
what i really want to know
what a charming door knocker
we don't have an anniversary or a song
or even wedding rings well couldn't you
make some for us
i like how they do with the jump cut too
oh that's great
and then they tap together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh damn we should be dicks and put that
last image in the thumbnail
absolutely
[Laughter]
i adored that first episode for a wide
variety of reasons
it's so crazy to watch a show where
every early reaction we read
it was like holy crap this is even
better than this
everyone's having so much fun and it's
so effortlessly
imitating what it loves but also is
bringing this
yeah it's like it's got the perfect
amount of like something's wrong here
this is so oh my god it was so
that was great that was great we're
going to film the second episode right
after this
won't talk too long but you know
christopher beck okay
kristoff back at me who i think did like
the ant-man movies dude props to
catherine han too
waiting to see if there's a post-credits
scene waiting to see if there's a
post-credits scene how long do you think
we should win
i really adored that a lot yeah
it was like it took me like it took like
two minutes to readjust
yeah and then eventually i was like
i just got eventually i was just
watching the show
yeah there was this one vision show
you know what i mean like the 1950s [ __ ]
i was like oh
i'm just gonna do the signal yeah i
don't know if they do a post-credits
scene especially
yes i would imagine not but there's two
yeah episodes so why would they yeah i
could just watch the next episode
i feel like if there is a post-credits
scene for one of these
through all these credits to get to that
post credit scene
because yeah because people watch
credits the same way on tv as they do
with
readers
freaking marvel oh no post credible
gifts
how am i supposed to know what to
endlessly nick pick apart and expect
next where to begin
okay my first thought is this is
actually bold and a unique way to start
off your show i mean i we don't know
what the next episode
is but to start off your show we're like
marvel
the next phase kicking off on disney
plus and this feels
nothing like anything it's just a 1950s
sitcom what i thought was great about it
was i was so curious to see how
how they'd uh do it all would it be like
a whole bunch of marvel references would
it feel like they're parrying
that era or that style of show i'm
assuming they're riffing on bewitched
yeah i mean for for a lot of the
especially the magic gags and things
like that yeah or just that style of the
kind of shows that they were back then
what i was so impressed by was that it's
not a parody
it's lived in it feels like an authentic
episode of that time it doesn't feel
like it's making
fun of that and once i settled into that
i was like whoa this is great
i love those kind of shows i really do
the main one i did grow up on i think a
lot of people did but the main one i
grew up on
was i love lucy watching this kind of
comedy again i like they're so
positive and delightful and just so
happy you know
like the furthest thing from edgy
watching it i i didn't find myself just
pulled into the immediate plot
like i want this dinner to go well yeah
and i'm like what is that thing on the
calendar
yeah it's so good and how they have an
anniversary and how it's like about
couples and husbands and wives like
so many of those types of shows watching
it they brought so much of the
aesthetics to life
with knowing when to go like yeah it's
your you know your cool mcu visuals but
then
the littlest touches of making it really
look like one of the 1950s shows it's
something as simple as
the choice to capture the wedding ring
with a jump cut
yeah of like keep your hands steady
we're gonna jump cut this make sure it's
the same friend
put the ring on someone put the ring on
boom you know something like that
those kind of touches because they could
have easily just done it where it you
know magically appears but to have like
the jump cut aesthetic touch
was something that was so grand i was
really moved i want to say everything if
it's only right that john gets to say
some things too no
please i mean i don't want to do any
work they're good paul bettany
was he was brilliant
he was having such a ball like
man it was great to you know hit me oh
crap it's freaking uh
we only got to see vision as paul
bettany briefly in infinity
war very brief to see him here and to
like redefine their pertinent like
really let his personality shine like
the if anything what they made fun of
was
wanda and vision but they weren't making
fun of
the genre or the type of show that's
what was so clever about what they chose
to make fun
yeah it's like they're taking the
divisive they are the fish
very much out of water in this very
traditional 50s sitcom universe and yeah
i absolutely agree i think it
shows the dedication and the love they
must have for these shows
that they went with all these you know
original style production
values you know having i would imagine
in the kitchen like everything was
probably practical and hung off of
strings
and those things yeah just give it such
a lived in quality that really do help
you immerse because they could do any
and all of this
with cgi and i appreciate that the
elements they do
choose to put in like little sparkles
when vision changes in and out of frames
right you know like those are cg
embellishments but those are very small
scale and they look very much
of the time and yeah like even the live
studio audience vibe i think that's an
actual audience it's
the first episode of elise yeah that
really brought an
error to it that enhanced the fun and
also really
enhanced i think the energy coming off
the performers especially elizabeth
olsen and paul bettany because we were
both
you know geeking out like he especially
paul bettany looks like he's just having
a ball
doing this and they have such great
chemistry and timing together and to see
yeah marvel go into something that
functions on both levels is really cool
because throughout this i was like us
you know they got these little details
where something's not right something's
off we don't know
like our origins we don't know where we
came from or how we got here
you know when we got married you know
like that's the it's such a clever
sitcom
like the writing is clever as [ __ ] like
it's really clever because they started
off with what's this thing on the
calendar and it's
it's a traditional sitcom bit you know
like what is
what's the thing and then they have like
with their phone call when he's at the
office and then they're having a
miscommunication where she thinks it's
something else entirely different and
there's going to be some
funny uncomfortable bits that arise from
this that's
a traditional sitcom type of formula to
do but they started
off with what's that thing on the
calendar then they just
like it's just a traditional funny sicko
thing and then they let it
slowly become a mystery that builds and
starts asking more questions and then a
little bit of it
i take a break away with that stark
toaster commercial thing
with a hint of someone's watching the
color you know i think that's what that
was at least alluding to
maybe star technology is helping out
with sword i'm assuming it's sword
involved who is watching all this happen
but regardless and i don't want to get
too bogged down theories we'll just see
what happens then they go to the dinner
and other than the commercial breakaway
suddenly the director
knew exactly how to transition us into
out of shooting it like a sitcom
yes it wasn't like a smash into a
different type of shooting style that's
when i was like oh
this is so smart they are slowly
letting you feel like okay keep it in a
sitcom shot
let them be like dammit where are you
from just keep that on sitcom formula
then start doing your close-ups slowly
start doing your pannings
let the mood build let the weirdness go
you see that look on wanda's face where
she doesn't exactly know what to do
but there's something in her telling her
like what vision help him you know
vision go do something about it then you
break away back into the sitcom world
i'm sure every episode will feel
different
it's just for a for you're not you're
starting off one yeah i was very much
impressed with how they handled this i
sincerely mean that very impressed
absolutely i think the greatest strength
at least of this pilot is they fully
committed to both they fully committed
to having a really fun charming
sitcom recreating that faithfully and
also
laying a bunch of lore underneath it
that you know is gonna turn into some
craziness
yeah yeah and they both fit seamlessly
together you know oh it's clever
catherine hall was great it was cool
seeing i don't know the actor's name
i've seen
mo i've seen like the first seven
seasons of that 70s show so i was
delighted to see her in there
it was fun because like she's even
played parody versions
of ethel in that 70s show before so
seeing her back here like yeah
she's she's exactly who you'd cast
she's the quintessential ethel type
character and i mean the guy who plays
her husband like i know i've seen him
seen him in a bunch of stuff that's
period too he's one of those
guy actors yeah i mean they're all great
elizabeth olsen included
because more than just the script not
making fun of the
the type of sitcoms they're honoring it
really feels like they're
honoring i was under the impression we'd
probably get a lot of self-aware jokes
about the type of sitcom that's
where i'm coming from i thought that's
what we were gonna get all their
performances
elizabeth olsen included of course they
did their performances
not making fun of the types because the
type of sitcom performances
type of sitcom acting of that era is
very different you have very different
types of approaches
and delivery than what you would do now
is like on
i don't know i don't know watch him like
big bang theory happens
he's got a laugh track that's the one
we're going with
it's very different so there's another
episode of watch but i i just gotta say
like this was i was so pleasantly
surprised
way to kick off in the face anyway guys
uh what did you think about this
catch any easter eggs look i didn't okay
the name was heart on
on the guy on the boss's door and i was
like heart is that a marvel character
yeah what is that huh
every character oh it's just a clue to
what's on the calendar
it's so long getting caught up in like
is that an easter egg and i'm sure
they're aware of those things too
i'm sure they're aware of like you know
certain things you're gonna be like
focusing in really hard on and maybe
missing other things
they had an ethnic guy who works in his
office you don't see that a lot
yeah he's from sword that's right the
only way it's
possible for that non-white person to be
better than ricky ricardo i didn't see
many other ethnic people back then he's
the one for this universe
all right guys thanks for being here
subscribe click that notification bell
keep a lookout for our next episode hit
that like button eric you rock for
editing this
last but not least
michael linden my dude i remember when
we first started covering shows that
were coming out on disney plus
you're in sweden you were not able to
watch
so much content that was coming out
because it took sweden
forever to get disney plus and what do
you know there's a brand new show that
has a lot of hype
and here you are you get to enjoy wanda
vision
with the rest of the world who gets
access to disney plus
so michael thank you so much for being
here i hope you're enjoying the show i
know you're definitely watching it
i'm sorry that your favorite film
franchise bond has gotten delayed
yet again every time i'm building
anticipation for it i am not lying
every time bond is delayed you are the
very first person that pops up mine
because i don't know anybody else
as much as you so whenever i was like
man mckayla let's be really bummed right
now
it's so sad today we better cheer him up
in the shout outs oh yeah i can wait but
i know you can't
sorry about that anyhoo though i hope
2021 despite that delay
ends up a better year for you than 2020
didn't know there are a couple of scares
here or there
but kick ass in 2021 and
you know and tell us what you think of
the show love you bud